e gli attenti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono favi jerry kelly oggi
siamo qui con sul dj suri j power che ho
portato in minecraft allora ragazzi io
non arrivo minecraft da qualcosa come
tre anni più o mesi solo che suri mi
dice che c'è una modalità chiamata
skywards esatto
lui è il mio sensei perché io non so un
casato e partiamo con le scavo appena
allungato deve portarci anche a te mi ha
portato ci sono solo gasato sono pronto
a spaccare tutto ti seguo che tu sei
forte io sono scarso c'è una tipa guarda
c'è lo zombie con sopra cenate io mi sa
che pende il kit questo qui il kit
dell'area se non puoi rimorchiare anche
mai ma è ancora che scappa da me lurida
[ __ ] vieni qua qualcosa fa comunque
ragazzi da io direi che ha dei sussurri
ci illustra come come funziona mai siamo
su un'isola ci sono delle delle ceste
aprì la giusta via
apro la cella si c'è gente che sta
arrivando sta arrivando sta arrivando
questo cazzo diverso ed i tuoi di
sciogliere i punti e poi scegliere ponte
se amori sono molti tantissimo aspetta
che sono forti io lo uccido nostro caso
se l'è fatta che il giorno di merda
daniel k roncaccia levato un ponte in
culo resta il cazzo quanto dovresti
sapere queste cose ci giochino hanno
cambiato le modalità non è neanche scusa
eh va beh ragazzi questo era di
allenamento che lo spigola così poi
spiegano alla grande ci sono delle ceste
di prendere le cose delle ceste
prepararti subito con tipo spade cose
del caso perché la gente come visto
arriva subito cerca di ammazzarti
democrazia quindi ho entro e prendo
subito eletto tu apri le ceste per in
tutto ciò che poi fugge da così ci sono
le isole il tuo compito quello di
ammazzare tutti gli altri giocatori è
l'ultimo in piedi vince l'ultimo team in
piedi vince tipo highlander ecco questa
è un'isola nostra no esatto quelle sono
le altre isole la noi dobbiamo uccidere
tutti dobbiamo rimanere gli ultimi
invita ok dai poi c'è la trasmetta
claudio diamante con sì sì sì ci sono i
diamanti cioè fisiche ci sono anche
altre cesta felicità perché io pantaloni
pantaloni cose tu contro la con arrivi
nessuno e no controllo io controlli vai
tranquillo meglio cosa uso come arma
lascia nona ora ti do la spada tieni ai
la spada di chiamare la madonna 46
veloce è loro grazie ok a uomo sui
ragazzi ok ora vi dico io non sono bravo
in questo
non sono bravo del pd quindi
probabilmente faremo pagare però mai
l'importante non è vincere ma fare i
culi ok possiamo iniziare dare verso
un'altra isola abbiamo adesso di lì si
guada c'è l'infame di la attenta ciò che
non mi spari perché ho paura che quello
mi spara ma se vuoi cosa anche il
ghiaccio note come se da un lato zio
madonna quella come cammina sul bordo
vai vai rai rai spacchiamo tutto ma
aspetta e non sono capace né più maturi
basta che spariti o se spero che hanno
buttato giù un grandissimo gravissimo lo
pesco questo ma quanto sei forte
46 volte cazzo conto mi piaci fotti di
robe stai attento se si era poco arriva
la gente qui sei un [ __ ] genio a
tecla dozio cio torna qui tona cui non
stare lì così esposto ok ok è un
capitolo senso di vedo che lei voleva ma
c'è la neve piano di rilancio più casino
tu quando sai quando ripreso se parliamo
amore e dove l'accordo cazzo ancora in
corso ricordo quando gli usa non ne ho
rispondono dopo un po alla freccia nel
secondo te ne vai aspetti aspetti
aspetto di più soggetti ho ripreso a
chiariti e lancia addosso
boom di nicchia che mira l'ho preso ma
il prezzo le presone salva zanaria porte
è rimasto solo eric crt o se prima si
mobilito non c'è sul podio ma cosa a
meno che non ci ammazza eric c era
abbiamo vinto sia sto male
ok alcol altro sta arrivando è lì su
quell'isola in fondo lo vedi ma ecco
bello non so se ce li ha fino al di
prova
nostra sorte aveva forma aspetta aspetta
nessuna carta ti aiuto spetta fa il
ponticello
oddio è il momento ho visto cadere
guarda ovvio che gli addetti della vita
ma non più il ritiene più sera i rami
addosso diamogli d'auto di olo pesco
aspettano commettono indietro per la
genetica era fatta da pesca e io sta
tentando di pescarlo da un'ora e mezza
arriva hai ragione chi dorme non piglia
pesci come in faccia come in faccia e
guarda ora la tdt sono caduto sono un
[ __ ]
sono caduto decente posso vederla però
almeno dai dai dai dai solai sopra è
sempre sopra no come ho fatto a morire
come un rincoglionito ma porca era
guarda boom toni che ha fuori fuori
omissate un'altra boom nodi ma mia va
troppo in alto attenzione che è spenta
sta facendo ponte pescatore veloce
veloce non c'è ma ora torna parla dove
si è cagato addosso guarda come lo
massacrò di botte spaccagli le gambe
boom lo becco ma un po più presto spiega
la bravo e preparato che cazzo surreal
power lido l'incredibile ma cosa il
fatto di trovarsi una sempre più forti
fortunato levico miley skywards abbiamo
vinto noi ma noi sì ed è bene hai fatto
tutto tu quindi onore al merito e
soprattutto tutto teso sono tutto tyson
ti preoccupare vari che vinciamo che le
api le ceste vi riconoscerete spade uova
perché mi guarda cosa vuoi anche se una
sfida vieni basta la nuova che cos'è
no no attento alle uova le uova sono
infami ma lei poi ti passano a
salmonella e maurizio e questo continua
guardate questa sarà la giornata a
guardarmi può essere ice oggi esistenti
portato io arrivo arrivo riva ma in
altra un'altra meglio possiamo oddio
pazza e tutto tipo azzurri entra in
tutto rosa la città delle caramelle
marshmallow town
mele io sotto ti lascio la coop vaio
bisogno di prendere un basta c'era no
strano galline questo ho bisogno di
trovare di del ferro l'ultima diamante
qualcuno a tim creeper e io vado in
mezzo non lo zio fisica non l'ho fatto
non lo so perché altrove che il team non
c'è le cose in diamond è vergine andiamo
e mi sembra appropriato
no grazie che gentile
no se di ayas quando stavo scherzando
scherzando è il gal e la veglia si è
suicidata tra l'altro o arrivano
arrivano di voi non sai cosa mentre tu
gli dai buddha così lo amassero mazzola
matraia ma perché sempre a me [ __ ]
ma cosa vuole da me testa di cui avete
passato prossimo
il team foray fate subito parte subito
vai dai dai che questa rimanga della
curatrice tengo kit buona tengo kit
borini ma tutto che le nostre file video
ce lo que nos del napoletano
va bene un po di commerce o c'è una
città di diamante ok del legno legno
l'inglese bisogna vedere cosa ci vai vai
se c'è qualcosa non lo so ora pantaloni
e il mondo trovati robertson si può
rompere penn di tutti se gli amanti
bellini faccio io
daisy la continua servono lo so se con
quello dr4 giusto no eh sì per fare due
spade 23 dalle qualcuno sta per arrivare
li vedo li vedo
ma come li vedi è sia in pieni veloce
tieni 26 che non combattere siamo
cazzuti noi siamo cazzo che si chiama
davide 15 avrà riconosciuti ma noi li
facciamo il culo uguale pc io vado
veramente vai no più che altro pensavo
la mia cosa facesse una cosa ma in
realtà non ha fatto una cosa che pensavo
cosas ho capito poi via faccio il ponte
diga che i sensi balotelli vado piaciuto
vanno molto ci provo proteggimi e come
ti proteggo di lancio le uova ma senza
testa di culo weber carlo preso preso
preso l'auto anche io non cito uno
devono piaciuto vale ha ucciso lo sono
forte vabbè grazie alle gravissime la
prossima o chic come tutto fa vj simango
se molti la mango il team mango vi
mancava ragazzo mango fa vj sei pronto
spero favi già in mango su rialzato c'è
un piccone forse lo shopping e subito il
ferro è successo ghiaccio ghiaccio
abbassa massa massa dove dove dove sei
riceva sono in cima manuela diamante non
lo so se non che io ho visto aia sta
accadendo
sono caduto mi sono salvato sono morto
non ci sono ci sono bravo bravo
la storia sta al cuore hi fi in modo di
non morire trasmetta dove si aspetta
aspettavate
la smetta spettacolo arriva che mi è
piaciuto tutto scarso adesso è piaciuta
perché compreso della roma cerca cioè io
lo spero
inter ok ok buono buono buono buono
infatti l'armatura se poi sono rimasti
in nove team e tu sei da solo però pure
il presagio di morte e vai verso
un'altra isola ci sono il team rosa il
team viola che stanno combattendo come
mi sto impegnando per fare la fonte
i controlli che nessuno mi stia per non
c'è nessuno fidati di me ma ci sono
arrivato vai vai vai all altro spada di
diamante non ne faccio un cazzo de verso
il centro
ed è importante che tu vada piano piano
perché c'è il team dream che in teoria
anno come si dice hanno un po di
difficoltà non so se hanno tutta la vita
lezcano appena sconfitto quelli la viola
allora io corro salta salta azione ok
ora con call con molta calma calmissima
dove abbiamo visto già visto scappati
mentre la vita o colpisce ios cappio o
colpisce scappi scappa [ __ ] ci ho
provato ho parlato mi sentivo mi sei
piaciuto il potere è fatto bene ci siamo
pronti se si passa veloce della terra
odio odio ho trovato il kit che parte
col piccone buono ok così posso vedere
il ferro way degli stick
sì grazie così faccio subito i picconi
no stop a dire che hai fatto ma ho
sbagliato ho trasformato al legno in
bottoni giusto o i bottoni no grazie
sono un perfetto così però ho uno stick
1 cielo buono buon tieni ecco quello che
già c'è appunto che palle e servirebbe
un altro ha continuità cazzo vuoi infame
testo mi chiamo stato come ha fatto
eccezioni ecc
colpisci fa dj colpisce con pj abbiamo
risanato il blu e mi serve scusiamo se
con in stick però per forza è uno no
dato che altri sono botte voi dei
bottoni no grazie
perché devono arrivare
a rompere le palle anno ma cosa vuoi
dalla vita mia vai a marzo la mazzata è
come fargli brutto eccolo colpi ci
colpisce colpisce colpiscono la madonna
avevano già in altrimenti muoio comunque
a un botto ieri avanti o un diamante
anch'io dai vai aspetta la faccio le
varie sempre negli altri diamanti per
chi ha caricato alcuni angoli con l'arco
attenti attenti spettro di obiettare le
palle e va bene che hai fatto momenti
difficili della vita ossia saremo qua
sopra il 6 sopra l'albero vediamo
dall'alto non so come fare in modo di
scendere la julius utilizza la tua
tecnica di vita di minecraft un falco di
mai ho scelto un kit che non so cosa fa
o un magnete se siamo due contro due
volevi abbiamo appreso come capiamo a
lasciare o niente
ecco è arrivato su arrivati suonati
arrivo rivoli voglio pure morto no non è
vero
scherzavo lo faccio i sogni belli sono
morto
mai fa di certo casa ci ho provato sono
povere poi abbiamo vinto le rose
d'accordo ragazzine che possiamo
concludere qui questa roba io non avendo
mai giocato però credo di non so darmi
un giudizio senza allora è un sei e
mezzo grazie ai rischi e mezzo si sempre
che come me la mia media scolastica
quindi ai suoi spero che vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio suri per aver partecipato a
questa cosa e i ragazzi se vi è piaciuto
la solita lasciato il momento ero mi
piace anche la pace di facebook e come
votare iscrizione dei figli 16 vediamo
prossimi video cascato telecomando in
favore ci sta bene ragazzi